تونس الظاهره التي تستحق الدراسه والتمحيص
وتستحق دقه نقوسي خطر عاجل وتطلب من البحث
عن فهم للطائره من زاويه علم الاجتماع
شرب الان هويته هو في تعدد التجاربه
استهلاك المخدرات بمختلف انواع يمكن
يستهلك مره
ويتراجع عن ذلك ولكن يمكن يبدا باستهلاك
ثم يواصل التجربه
ويلهم ممتعه بين ظفره الى او يرها تلبي
حاجيته النفسيه والاجتماعيه ونظرته لنفسه
وبالتالي مساله التجربه مهمه جدا في هذا
الاتجاه فيه نوع من التطبيعه ما عادش
نحكيه على الاستهلاك المخدرات كلمه 10 او
15 سنه
الماضيه الان وكانه اصبحت عاديه في
المدارس في الجامعات في مقارات العمل في
المقاهي في الاحياء الشعبيه في همم دور
الملاهي
باشكالها وكانه اصبحت المخدرات هي جزء من
عالم الشباب او جزء مكمل لعالم لعالم
الشباب
اقتحمنا عوالما مقفله ومسكوتا عنها
وتسللنا الى ثنايا ظاهره تحولت الى طوفان
اغرق احياء المهمشين والفقراء لكنه ايضا
تفشل في احياء ان راقيه واستقطب ايضا نخب
الفني والاعلامي والرياضه ورغم فوارق
القيمه والنوعيه الا ان تسنم الطاعه
والاستهلاك في تونس الشامله جميع الفئات
والطبقات
المخدرات الاجتماعي
لكن موجود لكن ايضا في الجهه الاخرى
الاشخاص اللي هم غير المهمشين وغير
العاتيين وهؤلاء ايضا موجودين
بجميع اصناف تجد عائله من شباب من عائلات
همم من همم الطبقه الوسطى العليا من
الموظفين ايضا همم من الطلبه كما قلت لي
يعني مندمجين اقتصاديه والمجتماعيا الى
ذلك وتراهم يستهلكون ايضا هدوم همم نوع من
الاستهلاك اللي هو مربوط بالتجربه الفرديه